i actually felt bad when uh everyone got
mad at you about the breakfast tweet in
your uh and your hotel because it was it
was like one of the few times i'm like
i agree with connor
i'm just like yeah yeah i you don't need
that much food for breakfast you really
don't
i'm a simple man for breakfast i don't
really eat it i tend to eat it if i've
got something big about to happen yeah
yeah yeah you know the cycling special
all right yeah i'll have some breakfast
because that's just a wise choice yeah
yeah you have to exercise but if i'm not
exercising i'm not eating breakfast yeah
give me a cereal bar at most right i'm
i'm not really big on it i'd rather have
a nicer lunch yeah
i'm not hungry when i wake up no no i
don't know how people can just wake up
and go like yeah i feel like a buffet
yeah no because like if i have a big
breakfast uh which i'm i've rarely
enjoyed the big breakfast because i'm
not hungry for breakfast yeah like that
means i'm just not gonna eat lunch or
that means i'm just gonna get hungry for
dinner at this really weird time yeah
which is like a bit early for dinner but
like too late for lunch right it like
[ __ ] up my eating schedule
the worst is being you know when you
like
you're kind of hungry when you wake up
yeah maybe you didn't eat too much the
night before yeah and then like it
really you really start to get hungry
like 11. that's the worst time because
you're like [ __ ] it's too early for
lunch but yeah i'm holding out but i
don't want breakfast
for breakfast i'm holding out here for
my goddamn life
and uh
oh my i just i think i think what it is
is that i
i hate the feeling of like having a food
coma before 12 p.m yeah yeah it's like
because you you're just tired
in the morning and i'm like i don't want
that do you down a bunch of water when
you wake up yes i mean i'm normally full
from that as well i drink
like
yeah yeah i i drink at least like
minimum two or three cups yeah i also
just want to get stuck in with my day
like if i need a shower i want to do
that i go start working right i just
kind of want to i kind of want to get on
with my day i don't know i don't really
want to sit around [ __ ] around and just
eat something yeah like like having
having like a fry up that that means
something that means it's like a special
occasion you know it's like i can't have
a fry up every day i don't even
recommend you have a fry up every day
but like even cereal
even just cereal to me is just that's a
big meal for breakfast yeah to me like i
a lot of people say breakfast is the
most important meal of the day um i
don't know how accurate that is no
that's the [ __ ] cereal company's life
the cereal companies have tricked us
making us think that these [ __ ] carb
monstrosities are necessary i do not
need corn flakes when i wake up
[ __ ] the most i'll eat for
breakfast is a single banana
like i'll have this
they're putting their
important chemicals in the cornflakes to
turn you gay
so they've got the frogs get that's
right frosties only many frosties look
the most i have for breakfast is like a
banana and that's like oh yeah yeah
that's that's me that's me done yeah
yeah i know the fruit companies aren't
trying to convince me
you know the whole the whole chart
[ __ ] came from the the pyramid of
what you should eat in your day and you
should eat this much better oh yeah and
it's just complete nonsense the food
pyramid scheme well yeah and like the
whole idea of that you need to eat these
uh cornflakes which offers no
nutritional value in the morning and
stuff like that yeah like wheat was at
the bottom right yeah it's like no it's
like no it's not it was it was all
pioneered by these uh you know companies
but way back that they had an agenda to
promote their stuff yeah and of course
if if if you're the kellogg's team
you're gonna and you you have your
scientific research team the conference
you're gonna be like hey
hey uh kellogg's scientific team could
you maybe
maybe you know no i'm not saying to
excuse the results but like if there was
some kind of correlation that said that
callux is good for breakfast yeah really
help us out here that would i'm not i'm
not saying you should convince the world
that fruit loops is healthy or anything
but you know just like
maybe like a hint at the same time
because we really need to solve this for
it
that contract for five years is you know
not gonna be necessary if no one's
buying corn flakes so uh uh you know i
yeah
i i don't know what age i just was like
no more cereal for me i won't do it i
don't really ever eat cereal anymore i
was i wasn't brought up in a cereal
household so i never got the craving of
it and there's a toast house yeah and
not like cereal to me always tastes like
a sweet like a dessert what do you go
for it depends what you have i will say
and i've just shot on cereal for like
five minutes yeah but i do like i do
like bran flakes i really really likes
are good i love brands yeah they're good
but like i remember one time
one time as a kid when i discovered
brown flakes i thought these are so good
that i just will keep eating them all
day yeah so i had the whole box in one
day
and uh that was me in cocoa puffs yeah
and uh yeah but bran flakes is like
fiber on crack
oh lord my toilet activity that day yeah
i was
i i imagine they they had the they were
filming lord of the rings mortal scenes
out of my my bathroom than that yeah it
was [ __ ] horrible i was nothing i was
so much pain there's nothing worse than
an overly fibrous [ __ ] oh my god i was i
was scared i was genuinely scared i was
like 12 years old and i was like why do
they make them taste so good yeah i've
got flakes oh my god yeah i used to have
a [ __ ] horrible diet when i was
little but everyone does
your parents are like yes go on eat
those gummies that were made in the
[ __ ] ninja
turtles sewer yeah cause like because
like my my parents had no retaliation on
giving me my sister like cocoa puffs and
like uh fruit loops and like yeah
nutrigrain and all the [ __ ] like
sugary cereals i understand you know now
when you're a parent that it's it it
seems very difficult because you're
already
kind of struggling just to get by the
last thing you want to do is start like
comparing cocoa puffs with you know it
it shuts the kid out for 10 minutes give
him the [ __ ] cocoa puffs right yeah
yeah but then later on you're like all
right maybe i shouldn't have given that
kids uh four slices of nutella bread
everywhere maybe maybe 50 grams of sugar
for breakfast yeah that wasn't a good
idea i feel like it was a blessing that
i didn't just like i didn't discover
nutella until like i wasn't oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so so my god if i
discovered nutella as a kid which a lot
of people did
i like my diet would have been destroyed
yeah
my diet was destroyed because it's like
oh okay you had cocoa puffs for
breakfast and then my mom would pack
nutella sandwiches for lunch and i'm
just like how did i not gain a million
[ __ ] pounds yeah luckily when you're
young it's much easier
young young and asian
that's like the food
hack right there right exactly i despise
that my mom kept up with like what was
healthy because it just meant that i i
never got to eat anything fun and all
the kids around me always had like
remember the one there's one kid okay
unfortunately
but he always had chocolate spread
sandwiches i actually that sounds so
[ __ ] cool yeah this man had literal
chocolate bread man i'm out here eating
my [ __ ] cheese sandwich like a
peasant
this man is eating like a king he's
getting chocolate spread with his
chocolate yogurt bro oh my god he's
eating eating good but then but then he
wasn't eating
he was actually dying
his parents unfortunately set him up to
fail
it was good and uh when i tried it i
thought oh this doesn't taste good
does it not no chocolate spread doesn't
and like chocolate mousse and all that i
didn't really like that yeah and uh i
think chocolate mousse tastes good
maybe just because it wasn't normalized
for me i i hardly had it so every time i
did have it i'm just like oh i'm having
chocolate for a meal this is uh this is
a life hack right here this is exciting
uh i love cheese strings cheese straight
cheese strings cheese awesome but
even now i enjoy eating the chicken yeah
he's peeling it yeah yeah that's the
thing i i definitely enjoyed this
process
like trying to get it as thin as
possible as well just like like trying
to get like that perfect like it's just
like oh yeah
oh i don't know if they have this do
they have oddly satisfying moments yeah
southeast asia cheese strings
they don't think they do
it's just like this like it's it's it's
it's it's it's almost cheese yeah yeah
it's it's it's in all the imports it's
like supermarkets it's like not real
cheese i don't know how they do i don't
know it's not real cheese but it tastes
better than real cheese in a sense but
then it doesn't but like it's like
cheese flavored plastic it's it's like
playing a mini game to eat cheese and
for some reason that just adds to the
flavor i don't know why
we've never had them yeah i used to i
used to do this thing when i was little
i don't know if i'm the only one but
like i would i wouldn't like rip it and
then immediately eat it yeah i would
kind of rip it and try and like create a
perfect pile of like perfectly strong
jesus that's like that's a hannibal
and then i like put it in a row and i'm
like my fight is
making perfectly cut-off string cheese
displaying it
oh yeah
oh my gosh never had a cheese never had
it you're missing out you're missing the
the flavor is [ __ ] but yeah i feel i
feel if you're an adult and you've never
had string cheese as a kid it's a kind
of a hot tall hurdle to like giddy
there are some things that i try
nowadays in japan and i'm like i've
never had a japanese childhood but i
feel the childhood in this certain snack
you know what i mean like
like so some of the stuff we tried in
the combini episodes right with uh with
that that [ __ ] crisp thing that was
like that was just like one big whatsit
or whatever my ball oh yeah oh my ball
and i'm just like i've i can feel i can
see myself eating this as a kid yeah
they also had like the fish cakes which
was vile they're like oh the what the
carbocation maybe uh like the fish and
cheese or something oh yeah oh yeah yeah
that was disgusting
yeah i had both of those when i was a
kid
i was like oh yeah
just like just
anything that was like of that size i
would just try to feel like yeah like i
realized there are some things that if
you didn't grow up with it uh you
probably wouldn't enjoy it like in time
in in thailand we have this snack called
taro which is like yeah taro which is
basically just dried fish quiet
southeast asians
which is just like what is it it's just
like dried fish right it's just
yeah yeah it's like it's like it's like
because when i think of tower i think of
the purple uh like sweet potato i have
no nothing to associate with
yeah so so i remember like
eating this as a kid and thinking this
tastes amazing and i brought some back
to england and i gave something to my
mates and they had they had a bite they
were like this is just fish food i'm
like this isn't fish food
yeah yeah it's that it's that it's that
i've had that one yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
fish
fish drinks basically fishy like cheese
strings but with fish they took the fish
and they did this
basically
they stopped making strings out of
everything
i mean i just hear that story and i'm
just like oh
vegemite is over here being like first
time
i never got married
every time every time i like because i
grow up with vegemite as well then every
time i give that to someone who's not an
australian and they're eating they're
like oh this tastes like poison i
thought it would taste good on toast
it's brilliant on its own
it's lovely on toast i mean that's just
the brick coming out i'll just put it on
top still it'll taste good
does it spread enticing
but put beans on toast i've had you know
what else is actually good at with is on
rice
major amount of rice is actually not bad
because if you think about it it's the
same thing as putting it on time
i don't know who you offended more like
the australian in you or like the
japanese in you but you you somehow like
offended both your ancestors at the same
time yes definitely like i i definitely
got disowned the moment i said that on
camera
just died somewhere
a rice farmer just died
oh no
i tried it once because i i actually saw
it on japanese uh on japanese youtube
though cause they were like okay so my
australian friend brought back this
vegemite thing i had it on toast thought
it was disgusting but then i thought i'm
japanese put that [ __ ] on rice
anything's good on rice tried it and
apparently the the guy said it was good
so i was like all right well if the guy
on the internet said it was good
obviously it must be true they must be
true if a japanese guy said on the
internet it must be even if the week
says it's good i'll try exactly that's
wow exactly so i tried it and i was like
okay you know what not as good as on
toast but possible possible